[Music]
yeah it might be Priyanka tropa's 40th
birthday but this love story is
something everyone can celebrate my life
is very good right now very excited and
we're always excited to see these love
birds cozy up like they do in Nick's
tribute post on Instagram as the pigs
show priyanka's Milestone Birthday Bash
pulled out all the stops including
intimate moments on the beach fancy
dinners gifts from her hubby and even
some nighttime fireworks there's so many
things and check out this Revelation the
singer's nickname for Priyanka Nick
writes in the caption quote happiest
birthday to my love the jewel of July so
honored to be on this crazy ride called
life with you I love you and in case you
missed it we saw Nick show off a
custom-made towel bearing the pet name
Priyanka is here for the birthday love
too commenting on Nick's post quote love
of my life days I have a lot of faith in
who my husband is and I know I have a
lot of faith in the rock that he is for
our family the b-day weekend comes as a
couple also celebrates their baby girl
earlier this year Nick and Priyanka
welcomed their first child daughter
malty Marie Chopra Jonas
and when speaking with ET recently Nick
opened up about fatherhood you posted a
beautiful picture of you in multi what
did how's fatherhood been for you
because everybody says it's
life-changing to you it is certainly
life-changing she's uh she's amazing
um brings me a lot of Joy all is good
speaking of special names little mossy's
name pays homage to priyanka's Indian
Heritage malty and Sanskrit means small
fragrant flower or Moonlight it's just a
special thing in March we learned more
about how the duo is adapting to life as
mom and dad
ET Source explained quote Nick and
Priyanka love being new parents and they
have been spending a lot of down time at
home the source added quote Priyanka and
Nick are private but have let close
friends and family meet their baby you
know you love seeing your your family
happy as next year with E.T back in May
they're also making sure music will play
a big role in multiple his life has your
sweet daughter heard any of your music
yet have you played anything for her a
few things okay uh and I I sing to her
you know I love singular and um yeah you
know it's it's beautiful what's on the
playlist are you singing lovebug
[Music]
again
uh no I'm singing just a lot of you know
old classics
my wife kind of plays her more of a
stuff that's on the iPod or whatever I I
think
[Music]